you
hi everyone is Jerry if you enjoy Tessa
and physics this game is likely of
interest to you
in 1933 Princeton USA Albert Einstein
played against Robert J Oppenheimer
Einstein was white in this game and
opened with e4 Oppenheimer replied e5
Knight f3 knight c6 and Einstein now he
likes the most theoretical opening and
chests namely the roy lopez or spanish
game with Bishop b5 that bishop is
kicked back to be three-night f6 ensues
with pressure on e4
this is ignored white instead focuses on
development focuses on potentially the
gain of time with rook to e1 should this
pawn be captured and it is Knight take C
look e one d5 reinforces the central
Knight and now a four following the
general principle of trying to open the
position up when you have a lead in
development or creating pond tension in
other words white looks to exploit maybe
this pin on the a file after a takes B
but the move itself
a4 is ill-timed because of how black
could have been replying in the game we
saw something reasonable enough B for
keeping the position closed but what was
best is to ignore the threat on b5 and
instead develop Bishop c5 and put
pressure on f2 to which there's not a
good reply
what's objectively best is to it's a sad
move to have to make but to have to
return the rook to f1 is probably best
plank to e2 to defend laterally and say
well I'm going to keep my rook still in
this half open file is now mount with
Bishop g4 and this White King side pawn
formation is going to get crushed soon
enough with Bishop takes Knight so we
didn't see that we didn't see Bishop c5
in response to this a4 move and so a for
again not not the best move what would
have been better than a4 well what would
have been better is Knight c3
development with pressure on the one
piece that's finding itself in your
territory Knight takes Knight pawn takes
Knight and I'm showing this particular
variation for a few
reasons one it'll draw our attention to
patience and chess another is pawn
structure and well the third thing we
actually get to see some interesting
fireworks there's a cool combination
that I came across when I was reviewing
for this game with the help of a
computer so I'll show you those three
things right now so should this move how
come about Knights III and it's capture
and the recapture what do you do right
now as black because both of these pawns
are hit twice which have been Queen
converging on d5 Knight and rook
converging on e5 you can only save one
suppose black chooses to save this one
if you'd like to pause the video how
would you reply as white in this
position okay the move Knight takes e
let's see what's wrong with it
Knight takes Knight rook takes knight c6
reinforces d5 seems so simple but let's
look even closer because this pawn
structure alone is fantastic because it
kills this Bishop on b3 because of this
pawn structure and its control over c4
this Bishop struggles to do anything
constructive for the remainder of the
game it's important to recognize that
and not go right in for this capture on
e5 but instead to be more patient
recognize the potential stronghold that
black can be forming against your
not-so-healthy pawn structure and not
not-so-healthy doubled see pawns and
this Bishop that's caught in the middle
of it so what do you do instead of
taking on e5 you play something like a
four trying to soften up this Queen side
structure maybe looking to capture
capture on a divert the Queen away from
defense of d5 it flipped to b8 well now
here comes this tactical sequence that I
was talking about these fireworks again
with the help of a computer I was
finding these Queen d7 defending the
knight notice how there are these
exchange sacrifices that come about
where this night now pounces on this
black position
hitting the Queen Queen d6 is well now
it's met with Bishop f4 if you avoid
that with Queen b6 now out of the blue
comes this Knight takes f7 giving more
material Queen f3 check this is getting
very crazy if the King is going to the
e-file there's Queen takes D all sorts
of stuff for white rookie 5 although
white is down a full rook in this
position this black king is dead there's
rook g5 stuff Queen h5 maid mate threats
in the air if h6 so the King can try to
run away here comes the bishop threats
of Bishop to e4 book takes east 6 if
Bishop takes Bishop Queen f5 stuff
there's no good defense for black in
this position in short and again this is
just a variation I wanted to show to
highlight those 3 things these fireworks
that we just saw the pawn structure and
being a little bit patient with going
right in for this material grab on e5
getting the material back we didn't see
any of that we didn't see Knight c3 in
this game
a4 instead b4 is the reply and now d3
Knight c5 pressure on this Bishop Knight
takes e5 if Knight takes Knight the rook
will take and then you're actually
losing on d5 so Knight takes Knight was
not played in this position instead it
was 97 Queen f3 threatening something
very direct a matin one on f7 f6 defends
against the mate but this is a big lemon
this is not a good move best is Bishop
e6 because of this f6 move as king is
dead this weakens this diagonal and
white pounces on it right away
Queen h5 this Knight best not block
because you have this discovered stuff
going on so g6 was played Knight takes G
pins everywhere we actually get to see a
ton of different pins in this game
exploiting the pins on the e-file the H
file right here after the Knight is
captured the rook is dead there's no
good solution for black in this position
and white is now in this
the wonderful position of being able to
pick your favorite way to go about
winning Knight takes bishop is what
follows pawn recaptures Queen d6 another
pin is going on on this 8th ranked the
King gets out of that Bishop takes
Bishop b7 another pin now on the seventh
rank the rook is there to defend white
is getting all their pieces working now
with the Knight d2 c5 the other piece
all their pieces are working right now
for white rook to d1 opposite the King a
five-night c4 very nice move hitting the
Queen if she has to move then more
material will fall
pawn takes Knight pawn takes another pin
now against the black Queen Queen takes
rook rook takes Queen the King is kicked
away from the defense of the night
Bishop takes Knight and black gives up
at this point resigning so a very
interesting game again for those of you
who are interested in physics I imagine
especially and if you'd like to in the
comments section below feel free to
share what you think the rating or the
strengths of both players are so that's
all for this video as always I hope you
got something out of it take care bye
you